Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and we're going to go back now to the final segment in our show about
endings recorded live at the paramount theater in Seattle. All right,
we're going to close the show at, we're going to shift the mood a bit.
We're going to close out this show and our tour with a very different kind of
ending.
Yeah, cause unlike dinosaurs, you know,
dinosaurs have no idea what's ever going to happen to them.
But in this story we have an ending in which the enders can see what's coming.
It's coming right at them. Not Fast, but in this case very slowly.
So can you guys hear me easily? Easily. Okay, good.
We'll introduce you to two guys. Chris Jones and Dan Moran.
They both actors in Manhattan both been doing it 30 40 years,
30 40 years. Plays movies, you name it,
five woody on arms body gassers pantomime circus, two in season on Broadway.
Dentelle moonstruck the share moving a lot of Shakespeare, a lot of comedies.
They worked pretty much everywhere there is to work as it happens.
I know this story because Chris, one of the actors is an old friend.
We met in a high school musical actually many years ago. Oklahoma.
You think everything is Oklahoma? I didn't,
I don't know anything goes [inaudible]
[inaudible]
our story for both Chris and Dan begins 10 years ago.
Dan was on stage, big stage, Washington DC. I was doing
the street car as in streetcar named desire and he was playing the lead role.
Stanley Kowalski. You're the guy that Marlon Brando made famous for yelling,
Hey,
that guy,
the a woman playing Stella said it's really sexy how your left arm doesn't swing
when you walk. It's kind of like animalistic.
I said, well that's cool. So you used it, you thought, alright,
if it works it works.
I'll just play the character that way is the guy whose arm doesn't swing. But
I, after the show ended, I was walking down the street in Manhattan. I thought,
why isn't my left arm swinging? What's going on?
Well, Chris,
so right out of around the same time he was in Delaware shooting a film movie by
m night Shambhala, kind of a great movie fiesta.
Me called the village
marks.
I played Adrian Brody's father and while getting ready in wardrobe one day he
noticed that
I had a slight tremor,
occasionally difficult time buttoning buttons with my right hand.
I thought I had a pinched nerve in my neck.
I went to see an orthopedic guy and he said, you should see a neurologist.
I went to a doctor and he said,
very gleefully, I think you've got Parkinson's
and he hasn't run a deficit in the Parkinsonian and pleased he is able to help
me out. He nailed it.
Now Parkinson's,
if you ask an expert, which we did, Cheryl Waters, Columbia know
firstly medical center. Parkinson's is a very mysterious disease.
I'm not sure what to think about it now because it keeps evolving and changing.
Some people go to Dr. Waters when they get the disease and nothing happens,
nothing.
They come with tremor and they die with a little bit of tremor and nothing else
ever happens. But in other cases, for some reason it could wreak havoc
[inaudible]
because sometimes, and doctors really don't know why this is the case,
sometimes the disease will just start to march through the brain.
It'll begin deep down, low
down in the brainstem, and then it will gradually inches weight upward.
First of all, detect this little cluster of cells in the middle of the brain,
that control movement and that's when you start to do this shakes and then
little by little there's a progression progression up a migration to the surface
to other areas of the brain that control thinking, memory,
concentration.
And in those cases the disease is an extra bleak progressive.
So you got these different kinds of Parkinson's one that sleeps,
it goes on the rampage.
The problem is when you're diagnosed you can never quite be sure which kind you
got because for the people in whom it spreads,
it can take decades.
Ooh.
When he said you have Parkinson's,
did you feel like you were in trouble at the time? I know it was a joke.
It was a joke. This is nothing. I'm fine. In the beginning,
Dan and Chris didn't really worry a whole lot about this cause they didn't have
to. In fact, Chris, when I first was diagnosed and was performing,
he was doing a lot of Shakespeare and you'll,
if his hand ever started to shake a bit,
it was always nice to have a nice big cloaker Cape for me to wear it and hide my
hand behind so that the audience wouldn't see the tremor.
Truth is it didn't happen. All that often wasn't much of a deal.
Chris kept acting.
Dan kept acting and in both of them their Parkinson's seemed to be the kind that
stays asleep for
two years, three years, five years,
seven years. But then after eight years
the
just woke up. I just found out that he got hurt and a hundred a moon.
Dan says it's not quite sure when it happened,
but suddenly his limbs were aching all the time.
And that easy control that you have over your body as you're walking down the
street where all the limbs are moving together and you don't have to think about
it.
For him to disappear,
you'd have to think about each leg, each foot, independently,
left foot, right foot,
left heel, right heel to Chris.
He would actually have these moments where he would to move his arm where his
brain would basically say to his arm, whooo,
but his arm would just sit there and stuck like it wanted to move.
It just somehow couldn't. I would freeze on stage.
It was a nightmare
and as things progressed,
Dan would have these moments in rehearsals where suddenly he would just go
blank.
I had done this TV show on FX.
I had the one scene where I couldn't remember five lines. I just couldn't.
We were five lines. We'd shot all night on this
[inaudible] two lines and come back out. I love it.
[inaudible]
now this isn't an easy situation for anybody, but if you're an actor,
if you're somebody who has to inhabit a character,
the different rhythm than yours and different flow, use your body to do that,
which is how you pay the rent for that.
Sure. His Parkinson's is just awful because it kills their craft.
While your face becomes a mask too,
you haven't got your face and without face you don't have flow.
The way I liken it, if you take a pebble and you throw it into a pool of water,
it goes and there's a ripple that goes.
Just concentric circles go out from the impact.
If you take me my body,
my self as an actor and you throw a pebble into my pool,
it goes thud. There's no fluidity.
There's new. It just stops. I mean, once I,
I opened up to the, uh, acting world, I had Parkinson's,
my agents dropped me. The, uh,
cause pretty much stopped calling and that was that.
But then one night something happened.
How did this idea come up? Well,
it was my first idea in, I guess your brilliant idea. Thank you buddy.
And we should say that these two guys, Chris and Dan,
they've actually known each other for years.
The two of you met doing what among within country,
which is a classic plague on Broadway and Dan explains,
it was late one night he was having insomnia,
which is a usual side effect of the medication he has to take and he was just
looking around for something to read and he grabs this play off the shelf and
just picked it up. It was a play by Samuel Beckett and game
play in one act and he starts reading characters and Hammond clove.
I mean this was a play that he knew he had read it before,
but that night it seemed to talk to him in a way that was totally new
there. Interior gray light right from the start.
It started off in the Guy Shuffling onstage.
Clove goes and stands under the window, left, stiff, staggering walk,
shuffling around. He looks up in the window left.
He turned to look out the window right and I, yeah, I know shuffling.
He thought, I feel this guy
can sit, can't get comfortable. Seem familiar to him.
And then on the next page I am stirs another guy. Interested seem very red face,
black glasses also in bad shape. This guy stuck in this wheelchair,
can't walk anymore. He takes off his glasses, likes his face and the glasses.
Put some on again. So here you got these two guys. One can't sit,
one can't stand.
They're stuck in this little room with these two windows that look out and
outside those windows either due to an asteroid,
a nuclear holocaust. What used to be green is now gray,
like a wasteland. Is there anyone alive out there,
do you think? Oh No, no.
Okay.
Outside their window, they can see the ocean,
but it seems to have stopped moving. There are no waves
now in game.
Hm.
That's a term that comes from the chest and it refers to that moment in the game
when they're just a few pieces and just a few moves left.
The last few moves before the inevitable outcome. It's not the end.
It's the point right before the ad.
And it's the place where you become aware of the end for the first time.
The dinosaur can't do that, but these two characters,
they've run out of everything out of painkiller,
painkillers are gone out of biscuits and they have that awful awareness and now
they have to deal with it. Like here we are. Where do we do?
How do we fill up the time on this rock hurtling through space.
The more I read it,
it just felt like Parkinson's to me being locked in a room was my body.
Am I getting out? There's no killer. I'm not getting out of this room.
And then on page three, one of the characters,
a guy named Pam stops what he's doing and he says, enough.
It's time it ended and yet
they hesitate.
I hesitate too to end and dance has something about the line and yet I hesitate.
I hesitate too to end just flipped a switch for him.
Screw these people that won't hire me.
[inaudible]
because I've got this fucking little disease that makes me shake or talk funny.
I don't need those people. No. The next morning he calls Chris.
Chris described the call, you're sitting there and one day the phone rings.
Is that what's happening? He says,
how'd you like to get together and take a look at in game Christian members
thinking, I dunno, I'm not sure if I'm up to it. It's a 70 minute long play.
It's gotten 12,000 words and material is monumental, I think. I know that.
Let's just, no pressure. Let's just, let's just meet at each other's apartments.
So one day Dan would read one part, Chris, the other part,
the next day they'd switch. And they did this for almost a year,
the two of them each other's living rooms,
reading the play back and forth until finally they contacted the beck of the
state and got to put on one
live performance in New York.
We decided Chris is having more trouble with his movement than I am.
I'm more trouble with my speech and Chris's. So I thought,
well why don't I dig on the part with all the speech?
And you got all the moving. So when you do the pilot, the whole movement.
That makes sense. So you both leaned into your weaknesses. Yes.
We'll show the [inaudible].
The obvious question is why would two people in danger and in more danger over
time,
why would you decide to spend time staring at that danger straight in the eye?
Like that's just a weird thing to do [inaudible] and do it.
That's the only way to do it. I can't like go through my list,
my life being afraid of this fucking disease.
When he said that I didn't quite understand what he was saying cause if you are
legitimately afraid of something,
why would it make you less afraid to stare at it's details?
That would make me more afraid.
I don't know if it's about fear really. I think it's about knowing,
knowing what, knowing. Just knowing where you are, like where you really are.
You know? It's like a kind of journalism in a way.
Like I can imagine if you've got this thing that's been stealing from you for 10
years, right? Stealing your body. It's steering your craft at a certain way.
You want to know like where am I at? Am I in my past? It is,
the end already happened for me.
Am I broken or do I have something left?
I mean it's sorta like in one of the back of plays, not this one,
but an earlier one.
Their character waltz is on the stage and he says the following two sentences,
I can't go on. I will go on. It's like there's two sentences. Contradiction,
right. I can't go on. I will go on.
It's almost as if Dan is trying to figure out which sentence is he.
Is he the I can't. Is it done or is he the,
I will like he's got something left and the only way to know that is to look at
the thing that's posing the question. Yep.
What if you put on the play and you find that you get the wrong answer,
you find out I can't. This is what Chris was worried about.
The big issue for me was what happens to my sense of myself if we get to the
performance stage of this project and it turns out,
mm,
can I, I couldn't cut it.
And yet they go on
[inaudible]
after a year of reading this play back and forth in their living rooms.
Chris and Dan decide, okay, it's time to find a performance space.
Time to hire a director.
Oh they used to come dragging their asses into rehearsal,
looking like these guys are going to be able to go from here to there.
That's yoga. Fozzy Chris and dance director.
Shaky and wiggly as I used to call him. He's known him for years.
You did not call him back cause that's what they were doing.
It just says Dan and Chris for two of the best actors he has ever worked with.
And oddly enough, in this case, their disease could be an asset.
I believe that because they're halfway home,
they could feel what Beckett's characters in play were feeling better than
anyone. I never felt for a moment this wasn't gonna make the play better.
If they could get through rehearsals, easier said than done.
Take the problem with the medication. No, both of them.
When they're peaking on their meds, they are sharp. They're clear focus.
But when the med start to taper away, they get cloudy.
So the hope was if they were going to rehearse together, they some have to,
they'd have to time it just right so that they pop their pills at the right time
and rise together, get clear,
and then taper off together at the same time.
The medication gives you about an hour and a half window.
Might be just enough time to run a few seeds. Problem was,
it wouldn't always work. I'd somebody I'd walk in and Dan says,
even when it's time to chest, right. Sometimes the medication wouldn't take,
I would be completely locked up and Chris would be right in the middle of the
scene doing really well and then gets so tired he'd have to sit down.
Didn't have much stamina, so it's like that's just turn on,
go home or break out the mattresses. Sometimes Joe says they actually did.
We lay around on the floor or we just do something like you'd lay around on the
floor. Yeah. I said, let's lay down. Let's,
why don't we lay down and do the lines laying down.
That's actually a great exercise point is that a lot of times rehearsals were a
bust and as they got closer and closer to the performance day, Dan would say,
take me aside and say, you know, I gotta tell you Joe, this is okay,
but I'm scared out of my mind, you know, scared out of my mind.
So it became terrifying and I said,
well that's good if you know who are since when shouldn't we be scared right
there. And then he'd remind Dan of a basic law of the theater.
Terrible rehearsals make great performances most of the time.
But they knew this was a very different situation.
Very different at 15 oh,
thank you baby. Then came July 13th last year,
the people are coming the night of the performance.
Rosie, you got an understudies couple of minutes before the show.
Dan Calls for the so-called understudies and then runs to the back door to smoke
a cigarette.
I'm looking up this door and having shit y looked out and hash through it many
times before. Everything's seems familiar,
but
I don't belong there. I feel like, I feel like I'm [inaudible]
Huh?
Like, what am I doing here? He says, he kept thinking,
how did I think I could do this? I mean, I'm going to fuck it up.
I'm going to forget lines. I'm not the character. I'm not,
I'm not fully the character. I haven't rehearsed enough.
I haven't had enough rehearsal time.
And he says he actually walked out the door,
got about halfway out cause he's at that moment he was thinking, you know that,
I mean that question, can I or can I?
I've got my answer and I'm about to go out in front of hundreds of people and
show them nakedly. Then I am broken that I can't do this.
Does the end has already happened. Then he thought,
I've started this ball rolling.
I couldn't stop it. So no,
just do what you have to do. Just start at the beginning.
Go until the end and then the stop
[inaudible]. Okay, so the play begins with Dan in the middle of the stage.
He's asleep in a wheelchair, covered by a sheet. Chris Paces around behind him,
sort of shuffles about, looks out those windows. Mumbles,
it started off okay. Chris was very good where you're not getting a laugh.
[inaudible] Huh?
For sound. He makes, he gets a laugh right from the start.
The audience got back his humor.
That was a great, great relief.
But then the thing Dan feared most happened in one of the big speeches of the
play. You went blank. Oh my God. What's my next line?
I lost a line.
He says he stared down at his feet for 20 seconds and then his wife Ruth Fed him
a line and he went on. That was one moment,
but there was another moment,
a series of moments actually that were entirely different.
It began finish this finish just after Chris's opening monologue,
Stan begins to speak John de be misery
loftier than mine.
If I tried my damnedest to just stay with the story moment by moment enough,
it's time.
It ended in the shelter too and yet I hesitate.
I hesitate to to N.
Yes,
there it is. It's time and under acetate.
Dan says as he was up there making that speech,
that speech about how it's time to end and yet he hesitates.
A funny thing happened.
You know how my performance muscles started to take over his body,
loosened up his legs, his arms, his mouth.
Suddenly they were under his control in a way they hadn't been for months.
He can move them without thinking.
Let's was acquiring Michael Cole. Yes. Have you not had enough?
Yes.
We were able to do things on stage of what,
that's huge.
Just stretching the plate. It was like the disease was gone.
That's always the lay at the end of the day, isn't it closed? Always.
It's the end of the day. Like
any other day isn't even close. Login. What's happening? What is happening?
Something is taking its course
and then there we are. Good. I am. That's enough.
It was over
[inaudible]
it was amazing.
And then I remember walking back stage and Chris and I just burst into tears.
Well you just don't cry.
It was not so much about the release of doing it,
but I think and more to do with family,
our kids and our why and some really good friends could see that
there's still some kind of possibility and I do believe that it was mixed with
feeling like, Oh God, I'm going to miss this.
For me, a lot of times when I commit to a project,
one of the things that I'm sort of curious about is who will I meet in the
person of me in this project?
Ooh, who will I find in the room when I, when I work on the material,
I was pretty proud of
[inaudible]
who I found on this one.
There's something in this story that
it speaks to all the things we feel about endings.
I mean obviously it hurts. It hurts to end.
This is Dan says, and this is the line that gets me every night. Oh God,
I'm going to miss this.
But there's also something in with Chris says that if you stare unblinkingly at
the truth, you sometimes find something in yourself that you hadn't seen before,
which is in its way a new beginning.
So it's time. Yeah, it's time end.
You know,
we've never quite figured out how to end this show about endings except maybe to
follow Dan's simple advice and start at the beginning. Go until the end,
then stop. Yeah. So Ladies and gentlemen, we've started at the beginning.
We've gone to the end and now we will stop.
I'd like to go on a little bit longer. Just a little bit. All right.
Then Reggie, take us out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
this moment right here, this moment,
no one had a better view of this moment than me because I'm sitting there behind
the desk. You get out from the desk, walk to the side of the stage,
get the hyper-realistic T-rex, dinosaur,
masterfully puppeteered by Mr Myron Cuso,
and you guys have like a break dance dance off in the middle of the stage.
2,500 people just do not know what they're looking at because they're seeing
Robert Krulwich bust a move. I mean like busted moving that like, you know,
Young Mc like 1995 way busting move. It's like, it's amazing.
It's so amazing in fact that you have to go to the website right now,
radiolab.org/live and watch it.
I also shot multiple videos from the behind the stage cause I was like
[inaudible], I can't do this. It was so,
it was the most joyful thing I've ever seen.
And I want to thank you for that, Robert,
for allowing me to watch you do that night after night and for Reggie for
creating the music and for Sarah Upstate Darren, Greg Lynn Cocci, Keith scratch.
It was just awesome. It was awesome. That plus the musical apocalypse.
I will never forget those moments. I also want to thank our sound geniuses,
Jill de bluff and Dave Sanderson and Dylan Keefe and to our tireless fearless
and fear inspiring tour manager,
Melissa O'Donnell and till the woman without who any of this would have been
possible. Our director, Eleanor. Um, Chad had been run.
I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.
[inaudible]
get row one seat 10. Are you ready? Yes.
Apocalyptic o was performed live at the paramount theater in Seattle,
Washington by Robert Krulwich Jad ABIM Rod Kurt Braunohler,
Reggie Watts, Miram Guso Glenn Coachee,
Daring Gray, Sara lip state, Keith scratch. Um,
our production team was Melissa O'Donnell and Tom Jefferts. Jill did both.
Dave Sanderson, Keith Scratch and Ellen Horn,
scenic nvidia designed by Josh Higginson and Adam Schweitzer for work horse and
game by Samuel Beckett.
Presented it through special arrangement with George Burkhardt Inc on behalf of
the estate of Samuel Beckett, all rights reserved. Thanks. Oh,
special things to outback concerts. Nick Muciforo,
Ruth crush got married. Beth Cote,
old gym burned field and Kendra Snyder. Wow. Yeah,
that was a mind field of proper nouns and you got through it. Okay.
Also, while we're, while we're in the thinking, dude,
I want to think at the NPR music team for so graciously agreeing to videotape
this performance for us. So thanks to those guys with the cameras,
you flipped around Radiolab.
It's supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the Alfred p
Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
More information about sloan.org Radiolab is produced by W NYC and distributed
by NPR radio lad is hope radio lab is hosted by Jad ABIM Rad.
Our staff includes Ellen Horne, so wheeler, Pat Walters,
Tim Howard, Brenna Pharell, Molly Webster,
Melissa O'Donnell, Jamie York, Dylan, Keith, Lynn Levy,
and Andy Mills with help from Matt Kelty, Kelsey Padgett,
Aryana Wack, Damien Marchetti,
and of course Scott Brown doing pro pro pro bono credit re citation tonight
that that's huge. You give a health risk gov brown.